we'll be given by the Benoit's mom about
your fiction
okay so let me start off by defining
what I mean by restriction so a
restriction is just a subset R of the of
the Hamming cube and we'll be
considering random restrictions in other
words distributions of subsets of the
Hamming cube in the most common kind of
restriction that I'll be talking about
today are sub Cube restrictions okay so
and when R is a sub cube we can identify
our with a function which Maps the
coordinates to either 0 1 or star
meaning each coordinate is either fixed
to a constant or left free and our P
will be the P random restriction the
most common random restriction we'll be
looking at so here P is some some fixed
parameter between 0 and 1 and here yeah
so each variable is independently left
free with probability P and otherwise
set to 0 1 with equal probability
so restrictions are useful for proving
lower bounds in circuit complexity so a
restriction can be applied to a function
naturally you just restrict the domain
of the function and certain kinds of
restrictions can be applied to boolean
circuits and and other objects
syntactically so to get a lower bound
well if we can show that a circuit
becomes simple under a restriction well
some target function remains complex or
perhaps with high probability if R is a
random restriction then we get a lower
bound okay now there are different types
of restrictions that that one can
consider and that are used for proving
lower bounds here denoting them by the
kind of constraints which which
correspond so sub cubes you're just
fixing coordinates to 0 or 1 more
general kind of restriction would be a
monotone projection where in addition
you're identifying variables you can
think of this more traditionally as a
projection by identifying the all of the
variables in a given equivalence class
with a new variable if we allow in
equality constraints we get projections
where you can map to the negations of
variables even more generally one can
consider affine restrictions where
constraints are X ORS of some variables
are 0 or 1 maybe the most general kind
of restriction that I'll be talking
about in this talk are you know
restricting to a low degree variety to
the 0 set of some polynomials of low
degree ok so now that we all know what
what
getting stronger as we wind down right
exactly yeah more general as you could
tell so here's the outline for the for
the talk so go through some background
in circuit complexity and gait
elimination arguments I'll go through
this fairly quickly so next I'll talk
about the switching lemma so this will
be sort of the main topic of the of the
talk and in particular I want to show a
new proof of the switching lemma via
sort of entropy argument and this
actually leads to some stronger results
which I'll mention then I'll discuss
some applications of these stronger
switching lemmas and I'll discuss a
notion which I call criticality of
boolean functions and will show how this
this new switching lemma gives improved
bounds on the criticality of ac0
functions and from this we'll derive
some other recent results algorithms for
a c0 bounds on the Fourier spectrum all
follow from this result and criticality
that I'll mention and then finally in in
whatever remaining time I'll try to give
a brief tour of some of the other reign
and restrictions that are used to prove
lower bounds and maybe a particular
focus on recent result of HA stud in
improved complexity so these site and
grid projections that's the outline ok
so let's start with some background on
on circuit complexity and I'll go fairly
quickly through this since I assume
here's already familiar so circuit
complexity we study the complexity of
specific problems such as the parody or
matrix multiplication in combinatorial
models of computation and most
importantly boolean circuits and the
goal is to prove unconditional lower
bounds so lower bounds which don't rely
on any unproven assumptions and like I
start this talk whenever I say problem
I'm referring to a decision problem but
will regard problems as being
represented by a sequence of boolean
functions right which are encoding the
problem on instances of size N
okay so a boolean circuit is a is a
circuit comprised of a fan into and or
gates and negation gates we have our
variables here on the bottom by size of
a circuit I'll refer to the number of
and and or gates so the negations are
for free so circuits compute functions
an N variable boolean circuit is
computing an end variable boolean
function we say that a problem is solved
by a sequence of circuits you know one
for each input size if the answer
computer in a variable function okay so
you know this setting is in contrast to
uniform models of computations such as
Turing machines where we have a single
algorithm at solving a problem on all
instances this is the setting of circuit
complexity
okay so circuits given a very natural
and important combinatorial complexity
measure of function so the circuit size
of a function is the minimum size of a
circuit computing F so the minimum
number of and and or gates you need to
compute F so from the early days of
circuit complexity we know that almost
all and variable boolean functions have
circuit size 2 to the N over N both
upper and lower bounds actually and
these are by well at least the lower
bound is by a fairly straightforward
counting argument so it's important to
emphasize the goal in circuit complexity
is to prove lower bounds for explicit
boolean functions specific functions in
the class NP say you know this K clique
or parity whatever so the reason that
circuit size is such an important
complexity measure is that it's a sort
of non-uniform version of sequential
time so if you have a Turing machine
running in time T can be simulated by a
sequence of circuits of size T times log
T so a corollary if one could prove a
super polynomial lower bound on the
circuit size of any function in the
class NP then this would show that P is
different from NP in fact you'd show
something strong
that NP is not in P slash poly and
circuit complexity is widely believed to
be the most viable approach to so the
holy grail in circuit complexity prove a
super polynomial lower bound on the
circuit size of any problem in NP
unfortunately proving lower bounds on
explicit functions is hard yes
here's a table of some some record lower
bounds over time we see there's been
very slow improvement and the best lower
bounds we have today for boolean
functions is just shy of 5 n and right
if we allow parody gates as well then
it's slightly better than 3 n so this is
a recent result and all of these results
are proved using gate elimination
arguments which I'll discuss in a moment
using sub cube restrictions and the
setting and affine restrictions in the
setting
okay so an important subclass of
circuits are formulas DeMorgan formulas
and some and in two setting and formulas
are just circuits with the structure of
a tree and we measure the size by the
leaf size so the number of leafs you
know in a formula and formulas
intuitively are a weak model of
computation in that they lack memory in
the sense that the result of each sub
computations used only once and despite
this in obvious weakness it's open
weather circuits are actually more
powerful following sense so well there
can only be one Holy Grail but you can
call this may be a pretty Holy Grail
Eclipse proved that polynomial size
circuits are strictly more powerful than
polynomial size formulas however even
proving formula size lower bounds is
hard so here we have sort of world
records over time currently the best
bounds we have are nearly cubic with
some recent log factor improvements of
here the main technique well it goes by
the name of shrinkage of the Morgan
formulas so this this is using the fact
that de Morgan formulas simplify under P
random restrictions
so right so you can't prove strong lower
bounds for general circuits and formulas
so we study restricted classes in the
hope of developing stronger techniques
so some of the main classes that that we
study are they see zero setting this
corresponds to fast parallel
computations and these are boolean
circuits with unbounded fan and and and
or gates but constant depth or in
general bounded depth and the monotone
setting where we don't allow negations
there's also the arithmetic setting
you're computing over fields and you
have plus sometimes gates and tropical
circuits and so on and and right and
restrictions play a role in well at
least an AC zero in arithmetic settings
so right so here's a generic picture of
an AC zero circuit so without loss of
generality we can put our negations on
the bottom and we have unbounded fan in
and and or gates without loss of
generality you know nicely layered like
this and when I'm talking about AC zero
the depth is always bounded by some
constant D or if you prefer D can be
some slow-growing function of n up to
around log n we can of course also
consider AC zero formulas so AC zero
circuits with the structure of a tree
and in this AC zero setting very strong
lower bounds are known in particular
exponential lower bounds for each
constant depth D are known since the 80s
so it's known that the depth D AC zero
circuit size of the end variable
priority function is 2 to the N to the
one over D minus one and here again we
have a technique using random
restrictions this is hostile switching
lemma which we'll be looking at in some
detail and I want to point out that this
kind of lower bound this kind of
dependence on D maybe we could refer to
this as a size depth trade-off so the
bound gets weaker as the depth increases
this is sort of a limitation of the
lower bounds that approve via switching
lemmas so note in particular that lower
of this forum become become completely
trivial once dee reaches login and this
seems sort of inherent to techniques
using switching lemmas so you know you
get stronger separations above AC zero
we random restrictions are not going to
be enough okay so you know some of the
main lower bound techniques in in at
least the non non monochrome setting
we have counting arguments gate
elimination arguments these using
restrictions switching lemmas are using
restrictions on the polynomial method
which I will talk about in this talk
this is giving lower bounds against a c0
with parity gates just a brief word on
this this other restricted setting
monotone circuits
well so the point is we know essentially
all separations among interesting
monotone classes and there are many many
different techniques restrictions aren't
the main method used here so a lots
known and I'm not gonna be saying much
about the monotone setting okay so onto
an overview of gate elimination
arguments and shrinkage of DeMorgan
formulas well I should say you know
please feel free to interrupt me at any
point with questions
okay so we're going to be talking for
now about sub cube restrictions so we
have a boolean function f of n variables
so by restriction we mean a function
mapping the variables to 0 1 or star
meaning unrestricted equivalently you
can think of R as a partial function
from the variables to 0 so we can if we
apply our to the function f then we can
view the restricted function as a
function on the sub-q 'b over the free
variables over the stars of the
restriction maybe here's a way to
visualize that so here's our restriction
on the end variables so we want the the
restricted function on 0 1 to the Stars
well you just you just combine these two
and evaluate f
so right we can also apply a restriction
our syntactically to circuits and to
other objects so what does this mean
let's sort of do this by illustrate this
by example so consider a one bit
restriction so the R here is you know
the only variable which it fixes is this
is x2 it fixes it to one so here we have
our circuit so when we apply this
restriction the x2 becomes the constant
one so this one is feeding into these
two gates and or gate and a NAND gate
and so that note that this gate is
forced to to the value one here whereas
this gate just loses this wire so we
have this simplification and now this
propagates so this is this one now feeds
into two different and gates here which
kills these two wires and then the final
simplification step is we can note that
these three gates here all lost a wire
so we can bypass them and throw our
wires like that so this is the effect of
this one bit restriction on on the
circuit
yeah you're mentioning this in syntactic
simplification but I mean all the loved
ones would work okay under like crazy
simplification good yes that's true so
so for instance right when you talk
about the shrinkage exponent you know
you're not talking about necessarily
actions syntactically on the circuits
but on the leaf size yeah
okay so let's see when I talk about gait
elimination methods here's maybe the
simplest example of a non-trivial lower
bound so it's the following observation
if we have a circuit C which is
computing the end variable parity
function for at least and being at least
two then there's exists a one bit
restriction R which kills at least three
and or and and or gates yeah this is
only well this is this is true of
circuits which compute parity it's not
wouldn't be true of all circuits maybe
I'll leave this as a as an exercise so
but in other words if we apply the
restriction R to C then the size
decreases by at least three yeah right
by circuit here I mean with in in the
basis of and or not the size is not
including the not gates here and as a
corollary of this lemma so note that
when you apply a 1 bit restriction to
parity you get back parity either parity
of n minus 1 bits or the negation of
parity of n minus 1 gear and this lemma
would apply to I naught 1 minus parity
as well so as a corollary of this lemma
we get a lower bound of 3 and minus 3
and this turns out to be tight matching
upper bound so sort of leave this as an
exercise so this is you know you know 5
n is already state-of-the-art and here
we've gotten at least something which is
better than most trivial lower bound you
can imagine which would be just n this
is for above
this bounded fanon okay so this is a
just to illustrate what is a gait
elimination argument so by much more
sophisticated gait elimination arguments
that's the state-of-the-art lower bounds
so almost five n four circuits in this
basis and then this recent breakthrough
so for a long three n was a
long-standing lower bound in the full
binary basis so all fan into gates and
particularly you have parity binary
parity gates as well and there was a
these guys came up with a nice argument
giving a three plus one over 86 m and
here this is using a fine restriction so
it's going beyond just sub cube
restrictions okay just to mention some
further applications of these one bit
restrictions if you're looking at depth
D AC zero circuits and you try to do you
know to greedily apply the best one bit
restriction you know deterministically
so
do this repeatedly them the best lower
bounds you can get well at least uh one
lower bound you can get is of this form
so something barely super linear and to
the one plus one over exponential in D
so this is the method of deterministic
restrictions you can get this for the
approximate majority function and a very
nice algebraic version of this technique
which I wanted to mention from from this
paper it gets a essentially the same
lower bound for AC zero circuits with
parity gates via deterministic
restrictions which are actually low
degree varieties so the zero set us on
low degree polynomials so this goes by
the name of the method of certifying
polynomials so this is it's interesting
it's maybe the only application of
restrictions in the AC zero with parity
gate setting and I think a very
interesting open direction is to come up
with the notion of random restrictions
what will be my relative error this will
be replaced variable with what or you
constrain the variables to you just you
know you're looking at a subset of the
of the Hamming cube which is which is
the zero set of some low degree
polynomials and you know you say this is
a certifying polynomial for your options
constant on that set yeah yeah right
it's a global that's right yeah how
about TC 0 and be applied over there
sorry I mean in general we don't have
yeah I I'm not too familiar with all the
lower bounds and TC services so I'm not
sure but I think random restrictions
also play a role
okay so um right so next I'll talk about
the the most important random
restriction that we'll be looking at is
the period of restriction this is
denoted R P so this is as I said before
we independently for each variable each
coordinate we're fixing it to what we're
leaving it free with probability pre P
and it's setting it to 0 1 equal odds
otherwise a convention throughout the
talk at random objects will be written
in boldface
so this very natural restriction turns
out to simplify boolean functions
computed by DeMorgan formulas decision
trees ac0 circuits so for these weak
models of computation these restrictions
simplify these objects considerably on
the other hand certain boolean functions
like parity maintain maintain their
complexity remain complex under under
the pier and restriction and this gives
it lower bounds so so let's look at the
effect of RP on the Morgan formula so
boolean formulas with fan and 2 so the I
guess the first significant result in
the setting of spot of skaia
shows that if F is an N variable de
Morgan formula and you look at the
expected leaf size of F under a uniform
random one bit restriction so I'll pick
a variable uniformly at random set it to
0 1 uniformly at random then this
decreases is less than the leaf size of
F should be 1 over N 1 over N 1 minus 1
over N 1 minus 1 over N to the 1.5
but one bit for one bit it should be one
minus one point five over n ah good
right okay which is bounded by yeah okay
so as a consequence of what should have
been written here the expected leaf size
of F under a period of restriction is
bounded by order of well 1 plus P to the
1.5 times the leaf size and there is a
long sequence of works which were
improving this this Explorer 1.5 all the
way to 2 which is actually optimal so
this was this weaker version of this
bound was shown by T by huh stud yes in
this form was proved by Avishai a few
years ago and so this too is known as
the shrinkage exponent of DeMorgan
formulas and this also we get lower
bounds also from this shrinkage
phenomenon with formulas so this this
quite directly implies a lower bound of
N squared on the leaf size of the parity
function this is known by other by other
arguments like Genco as well but we also
get the state-of-the-art the strongest
known lower bounds for a different
function on as on Draves function
these are nearly cubic lower bounds so
right this is a the current frontier
so one open question which I wanted to
advertise is well what is the effect of
the PV and restriction on monotone
formulas so just like one has the
shrinkage exponent for DeMorgan formulas
one can define the shrinkage exponent
for monotone formulas and it's open what
exactly this is in for the class of read
once formulas this is known exactly what
the shrinkage exponent is it turns out
to be anything roughly which is roughly
three point two seven and it's
conjectured that the shrinkage exponent
of monotone formulas also equals this
this is a an open problem okay good so
onto the solution lemma are any
questions at this point
yeah
yes I think generally I mean the animal
a function is not closed under almost a
chance when you stick it about yeah yeah
that's good that's a good example
yeah so in order to state the switching
lemma let me first remind you what our
decision trees this is even simpler
model of computation and circuits so we
just have a tree where the leaves where
the non Leafs are labeled by variables
long leaf has a zero child and a one
child and then the Leafs are the output
values the depth of a decision tree is
the maximum number of variables or
queries on a branch right so this gives
a model of computing boolean function
first you read the variable x3 then you
branch according to its value and so on
integration output value so the decision
tree depth of a boolean function is
simply the minimum depth of a decision
tree which computes so for example the
decision tree depth of the parity
function as well as the decision tree
depth of the in variable and function is
N and having decision tree depth 0 is
equivalent to being a constant function
okay so the the switching lemma speaks
about depth to formulas so also knows
DNF and CNF formula so D enough for
disjunctive normal form so these are or
of an formula so you have an or of and
each of these ends you know has takes
literals so variables are negations of
variables the width of a DNF are seen a
formula is the maximum bottom fanon or
another is the maximum number of
variables in a clause and so with KD n
apps are simply called KD n FS for short
and note that a KD NF is the same thing
as an unbounded fan and or of depth k
decision trees okay and similarly CNF
sorry ann's of depth k decision trees so
this is follows from the fact that every
depth K decision tree is equivalent to
both a KD enough and a case CNF I'll
show this on the next slide this just as
an aside is a sort of weak converse here
so it's a boolean functions equivalent
to both the KD n F N and L CNF then it's
equivalent to a decision tree of depth K
times L just to illustrate this briefly
if you have haven't seen it before I
mean if I have a decision tree and I
want to get a DNF out of it well simply
for each each one branch of the decision
tree gives a clause which is
assignment to the variables on the
branch which lead to that to that output
value here we get a a DNF out of the
decision tree to get a CNF you just do
the dual thing on the zero outputs okay
so here's the statement of hostage
switching lemma which is the main tool
for proving lower bounds against AC zero
circuits so f is a KD NF equivalently if
F is an or of depth K decision trees
then if we hit F with a period of
restriction for any P we look at the
decision tree depth of the of the
resulting function then the probability
that this is larger is at least T is
bounded by some constant well 5 times PK
to the T this is the statement of the
switching
so the I mean this this holds in general
for any any P and any integer t but a
general one only really applies this
when your P is something like 1 over 10
K so that this becomes 1 so the way you
should think about this is that you know
if we take P to be 1 over 10 K then we
get an exponential tail bounce of the
decision tree depth has an exponential
tail down the probability it's bigger
than T is that most 1/2 to the T so
there's also a dual version of this for
CNS if you just replace CNF with PMF and
or with an than the same bound holds and
maybe just to mention them may be more
familiar version of the statement of the
switching lemons if F is a KD n F then
the probability that F restrictors or RP
is not equivalent to a TC n F is bounded
by this this is a consequence of this
but we prefer to this version will be
more convenient to think about so maybe
just to illustrate so here we have a KD
n F we hit it with a random restriction
where P is 1 over 10 K and then with
probability you know all you know 1
minus 1/2 to the T this becomes a width
t CNF so the way that this that this is
used classically and depth reduction
argument for AC 0 we have an AC 0
circuit with bottom fan and K we're
going to hit it hit this this circuit
with with the random restriction R 1
over 10 K and we apply the switching
limit to each of the second-level gates
and we take a Union bound over the
failure events okay and what we get is
that this this these these K CNF switch
to T DNFs almost surely provided T is
around log of the circuit size
now once once you've applied the
switching you have two consecutive layer
layers of or gates so you can combine
them into a single layer of or gates and
and so you've reduced the depth by one
and you've gone from bottom fan and K to
bottom fan and T or bottom fan and log
size so this is the way that okay and so
using this argument you can show that
the following lower bound for parody
which we mentioned before that the
that's D plus one AC zero circuits for
parody have size which is exponential
and n to the 1 over D it'll be sort of
just convenient from now on to think of
the index of depth by D plus one so
before showing the lower bound may be
nice to point out there's a very simple
matching upper bound so exist circuits
of deputy plus one and size exponential
and order into the one over D computing
parity they haven't seen it before this
by induction for depth depth to case you
simply have the brute force CNF DNF and
then for when D plus one is bigger than
three you have sort of divide and
conquer so you take the brute force
depth to circuit for parity over N to
the one over D variables and then you
compose this with the depth D circuits
for parity on into the 1 minus 1 over D
variables and when you combine me you
can you can arrange this such that the
the gate types on the bottom here are
the same as the gate pipes on the top
here so you can combine them to get
depth D plus 1 ok and if you work out
what size you get it it works up to this
okay so let me just illustrate briefly
how from the switching lemma we get the
this lower bound for parity so here we
have a AC 0 circuit depth is B plus 1
the size is s so you know at the bottom
of the circuit we have variables or
their negations but let's just think of
them as being depth 1 decision trees
well we want to apply the switching
lemma so each of these guys here is a 1
DNF so we're going to apply the
switching lemma with our 1 over 10 so
those are just some constant restriction
and then what we get are a bunch of
decision trees and with high probability
the maximum depth will be order log s
okay so you know each of these
individually is you know has an
exponential tail bound on its depth and
then if we just take a Union bound the
maximum depth is order log s well now
okay so assuming that this that this
holds then we're going to next apply a
random restriction R 1 over 10 log s and
we're going to take the switching them
on with respect to these CNF so these
ends of decision trees and again we get
the same picture we can death order log
s decision trees with high probability
we we repeat this and then finally we
repeat this up here and what we get at
the end we have a decision tree was
depth to 0 with high probability
so what we're left with is a constant
function with high probability you know
more precisely at the at the end of this
process we have a decision tree whose
depth is surely 0 and then
I said to summarize what we what we did
we started with the AC zero circuit of
depth D plus one in size s and we
applied a sequence of D plus 1
restrictions first there was a constant
restriction and then we applied d P
random restrictions where P was 1 over
10 log s but you can think of the
composition of these restrictions well
as simply a restriction our P random
restriction where P is 1 over order log
s to the D and then what we showed is
that this circuit under this restriction
reduces to a constant almost surely so
the circuit under this restriction is
almost surely constant so on the other
hand the N variable priority function
under some R P P is almost surely non
constant when your P is you know larger
than 1 over n why that is note that what
is the function we get here well this
will be either parody or the negation of
the parody function on binomial NP many
variables so so long as your P is is
significantly larger than 1 over N this
is almost surely you know not 0 so so we
have these two observations and
therefore it follows that the depth D
plus 1 circuits for parody require size
exponential and n to the 1 over D
okay so this is how how random
restrictions lead to lower that okay so
so can we do anything better for AC zero
formulas so recall a formula AC zero
formula is just a AC zero circle with
the structure of a tree so we saw this
upper bound on the AC zero circuit size
of parity and if we simply take these
circuits and convert them to formulas in
a in the naive way simply replacing each
one of you have overlapping sub circuits
you replace them with disjoint sub
formulas do this repeatedly your
circuits of size exponential in n to the
1 over D blow up this formulas of size
exponential and D times n to the 1 over
D so we have we have this matching lower
bound for circuits so by applying the
switching lemma and a more careful way
to formulas a few years ago is able to
show the similar matching lower bound
for formulas and this is a strong result
this one implies this one again by the
by this naive simulation of circuits by
formulas so without going into any
details let me just explain the main
idea and how do you apply the switching
Lama in a more efficient way in the
setting of formulas so let's revisit
this definition of the peer and
restriction and let's sort of view it as
a as a random process so I'll think of
this parameter P as representing some
count down times we saw it decrease from
one to zero and we're gonna view the our
P random restriction as a process as P
goes from one to zero so here's what
this looks like so to generate our
random restriction we're going to for
each variable for each coordinate that
is we're gonna take a random value and
zero one and a random timestamp which is
uniform random in the interval 0 1 so
here's what that looks like these blue
dots are the timestamps and here's the
random values now at time one's at the
start of time our random restriction
will be all stars so we only reveal the
values of variables which are above this
line here so as P decreases eventually
we reveal the first variable okay and
another variable at time P equals 1/2
roughly half the variables will be
revealed and so on and eventually P
equals 0 we've revealed all of our
restrictions fixing every single bit
okay so just to illustrate in this
dynamic view what were we doing before
when we applied hostage switching lemma
to AC zero circuits well we hit the
bottom layer of our circuit with exposed
at at time one-tenth and then we
decrease this by a factor of one over
ten law gasps and again we revealed
variables like this what we did and you
know the we exposed each each gate here
at the time which is simply determined
by its depth in the in the circuit and
if you're talking about circuits you
can't you can't really do anything more
clever because you're already getting
the optimal lower bounds okay but what
if we have a formula now is there
something better we can do and it turns
out there is so just to illustrate the
idea so what we're going to do is we're
going to dynamically for each sub
formula here or equivalently for each
gate in this formula so call this one F
we're going to dynamically assign a some
stopping time which I'll denote by Q of
F okay so a different stopping time with
for each for each game okay so some Q of
F for this
and so the way this is defined is sort
of by a bottom-up induction so to define
Q of F okay so assume we've defined the
stopping times of each of its children
so we're gonna let P be the minimum of
the stopping times of the children of F
and then what we do is we're going to
hit this you know the sum formula F with
the RP restriction for this P and what
we get are some decision trees out of
the switching lemma and we'll let K be
the maximum depth of these decision
trees so it's the maximum decision tree
depth of one of the children at time P
and then this leads to the definition of
the stopping time of F it's gonna be P
over ten times K and I'm not gonna say
anything more about I'm not gonna say
anything about the analysis of this
stopping time and how it leads to better
lower bounds but intuitively this is
this is doing something useful this
adaptive 'ti is sort of helping us it
was formula right to be 4-h something
yeah so so the the key here is that so
the underlying the underlying assignment
to the values is the same and we're just
exposing them at different times so
you're right that it wouldn't make sense
if we were taking different value
assignments that then that wouldn't make
sense so that's a very good question
this is the same input variable
it says go to the expose at different
times yes
but the value will be the same right and
the main technical result here is you
prove us a tail bound on this stopping
time so so this is the theorem you get
out of it you get this extra factor of D
in the exponent
yeah this doesn't give so you don't you
don't actually see an improvement that
the constant here is actually worse than
the constant here so you need depths
like eight or something in order to get
a something better so just to point out
a bit talking here about the lower
bounds for the parody function but maybe
more generally what these lower bound
arguments give or upper bounds on a
quantity known as the average
sensitivity so another way of almost
equivalent to this lower bound is the
statement that D plus one circuits of
size s have average sensitivity order
log S to the D and then for formulas we
get this extra factor D here order D
times log S to the deep
the one over d sorry there should be log
s over d and so what is average
sensitivity so the average sensitivity
of a boolean function is the the so you
take a uniform random point in the
hypercube and then you're looking at the
expected number of coordinates where the
value of f changes if you flip that
coordinate of X so the expected number
of coordinates that f of X is different
from f of X flip I so you flip the iFit
of X okay so so so now we come to a sort
of the main part of the of the talk
where hopefully I'll be showing
something new to the to the experts a
new proof of the switching lemma which
is based on a sort of entropy argument
and how this leads to stronger results
so I'll show I will show this after the
break but first I want to give a sort of
as a warm-up I want to show you a an
even simpler argument which is bounding
the average sensitivity of size M DNFs
and if you if you get lost a bit when I
give the proof of the switching lemma
then at least this is giving some of the
some of the intuition for what's going
on okay so let's consider now a DNF
formula F which is an which contains M
clauses okay so it's C 1 or up to CM
each clause CL is going to be is a
conjunction of literals so you know x1
and not x2 a and x4
so I should have said you so the this
should say if if f has width K so it's
it's a very simple observation that if
you have a KD enough so if each of these
literals has only K so each of these
clauses has only K literals then there's
a very simple argument giving an upper
bound of two K on the average
sensitivity and in fact you can show
that this this upper bound is is that K
this is shown by a mono a few years ago
okay what I'm going to show is an upper
bound of 2 times log M plus 1 using an
entropy argument I don't know whether
this is a this is a very simple it's
almost like a one slide proof I don't
yeah I don't know if it's been observed
before okay and that I should say this
isn't the strongest bound one can prove
you can by reduction to the to the
bounded width case you can actually get
something something better here but I
want to illustrate the this entropy
argument so here's here's here's what we
do so I'm going to consider a function
associated with this DNF which I'll call
the first witness function and I'll
denote by F tilde so f tilde of X is
going to output the index of the first
satisfied clause if if there is any okay
so the index of the first satisfied
clause if f of X is 1 and otherwise it
will output M plus 1
and so the claim is that the average
sensitivity of f is that most twice the
entropy of the first witness of f okay
and because this this random variable
the random variable f of X has has a
domain size n plus 1 then this is at
most twice the log of n plus 1 so this H
of F tilde here I mean the entropy of
the random variable f on a uniform
random point so this is basically a one
slide proof so let's see okay so here's
a just another way of writing average
sensitivity so average sensitivity of F
is the sum over the coordinates of the
probability that f of X is different
from f of X flip I probability over a
uniform random X now if if F is
different on these two values then the
first witness function is also different
and now so by symmetry I mean if these
two values are different one is less
than the other so this is this is equal
to twice the probability that f of X is
less than f of the first witness for X
is less than the first witness for X
flip I
okay and now we're just gonna we're just
gonna break up this event into into
these this partition this event into the
following events will take the sum over
all clause indices L of the probability
that the first witness for X is the elf
clause and the first witness for X flip
I is bigger than al
and now all I'm doing is I'm exchanging
these two summations and I'm breaking up
this probability into the probability
that f of X equals L and then the
probability that f of X flip I so yeah
so that xsplit buy is bigger than L
conditioned on now we can note that this
probability here this conditional
probability is going to be zero okay
unless the ealth clause contains X I or
not X I because so this conditioning
means that this clause is 1 and for this
to hold this Clause has to become 0 when
you flip the earth coordinate which
means that the 8th literal has to be
occurring in this clause
okay so so now we can replace this by
one if if the elf Clause contains the ID
variable and zero otherwise so we get
the bound that this this summation here
is that most the number of variables in
the elf clause
okay and now we have this inequality
here I claim that the number of
variables in the else clause is most log
of 1 over the probability that the first
witness of of x equals L may be to see
this more clearly let's just rewrite
this inequality in the following way so
the probability that the first witness
on X is equals L is that most a
probability that the elf Clause on X
equals 1 right and well this happens
with probability exactly 2 to the minus
the number of variables in the Alpha
clause
and now we're basically done because
this is this is the expression for
entropy well so here I'm just taking the
sum of the first l values of the if you
just extend this to n plus 1 and you
have exactly the entropy of the first
witness function
okay so this is a very very simple
argument which you know is is it doesn't
depend at all on the width of clauses
right isn't it in terms of log of the
number of clauses and yes it's Beit this
is basically tight actually the fact
it's it yet so without the factor of two
it should be tight so by reduction to
the width case you can get like log n
plus log log M so right so right there's
some loss in this factor of two so right
so what I'm going to do is something
actually quite similar to it so this is
just something I noticed and this this
actually prompted me to think about the
the proof of the switching lemma and to
try to do something similar so right
five minutes before a break I don't want
to get deep into this but I think I have
it better I think to take a take a break
now maybe we can start five minutes
earlier yeah so okay actually so the I
mean this occurred to me when I was
looking at this actually Amano's proof
of the Kay ever so so that's that's
using yeah it's looking at it's using
Jensen's equality together with the ppz
yeah that's where it came from
yeah I don't know I don't know a very
good intuition for why the entropy shows
up here and then in the proof Ostrow of
the switching lemma it's not actually
entropy that shows up but a different
function then we're using Jensen's
inequality right any any other questions
[Music]
on the entropy right because like you
sort of put them like all the mass of
Bible answer it's on the last one sure
if it's balanced you get like one yes so
then the log M plus one is like no tie
right so I mean I tried exactly what
you're suggesting so there's a different
one it's alright so the you get this
bound which is log n plus one if if your
if your function f has some expectation
mu you can get some other expression in
terms of mu something like something
like mu times log
like this right but but of course it is
interesting that we get an upper bound
on average sensitivity in terms of
entropy so I don't know if the entropy
of this first witness function is itself
an interesting quantity that I'm not
sure what you could do with it but
good so after the break we'll see the
searching
[Applause]